où sera Vladimir Poutine pour la Fête de
la Victoire du 9 mai sur la place Rouge
avec quel genre de discours il a reçu au
Kremlin le président kirgiz Sadir
Japarov qui sera un des rares invités de
marque pour la grande fête patriotique
et quel sera l'ampleur des défilés
militaires à Moscou à Saint-Pétersbourg
la répétition générale laissait prévoir
un défilé grandios comme d'habitude mais
d'autres villes russes plus proches de
la frontière ukrainienne vont
apparemment annuler ou réduire les
festivités de la victoire sur les nazis
en 1945 sa mère vote
changer le calendrier de l'histoire une
loi va fixer la Fête de la Victoire au 8
mai alors que le 9 mai sera le jour de
l'Europe qu'il va célébrer avec la
présidente de la Commission européenne
Ursula Vander Leyens et il prédit la
défaite de la Russie
le mal que la Russie répond à nouveau
sera défait dit-il tout comme le nazisme
a été défait
la veille de la grande fête a été
marquée par les plus fortes frappes de
drones russes sur Kiev depuis 10 jours
sont tous été détruits en vol dis le
maire de Kiev vitalico cinq personnes
ont été blessées mais c'est important
personne n'est mort la ville libérée de
Herson également a été bombardé faisant
huit blessés au total malgré ça le
couvre-feu de trois jours ordonné par
mesure de précaution a été élevé enfin
Odessa a été frappé également un missile
a provoqué un incendie dans un entrepôt
trois personnes ont été blessées et une
et portée disparue
des images ukrainiennes de drones
montrent que darkmouth continuait à être
bombardé la ville n'est pratiquement
plus qu'un amas de ruines mais elle
reste hautement symbolique
on pense que les Russes et Wagner
voulaient la capturer en l'honneur du 9
mai alors que les Ukrainiens tiennent
toujours bon dans un bastion de cette
autre ville martyre avant la
contre-offensive tant attendue
on ne connaît pas encore la date de
notre victoire conclut le président
zzinski mais nous savons que l'Ukraine
et toute l'Europe le monde libre vont
célébrer Jean-Michel le prince et du
Canada Montréal